politicians from around the world will
be gathering across Europe to mark the
centenary of the armistice in Paris
President Emmanuel macron we joined by
Donald Trump Angela Merkel and Vladimir
Putin among others at the Arc de
Triomphe in London the Queen will be
leading commemorations at the Cenotaph
with the Prime Minister and the Labour
leader well joining us now is Labour's
shadow defense secretary nina griffith
thank you very much for being with us a
hundred years since the end of the First
World War
why do you think it is that this war has
really become so ingrained and so
important for our national identity and
our national consciousness well I think
it's been very heartwarming to see the
real unity across the whole country in
really being determined to recognize the
appalling sacrifice that people made in
that war and the terrible loss of life
and I think from that as well what
people want to see now is also the
reconciliation so this weekend we're
talking about the signing of that
armistice we're talking about bringing
peace to Europe and we're talking about
the real determination there was to make
sure that nothing like this ever
happened again now we know that suddenly
that was not the case
but I think it's very important that
when we look back and we remember and we
remember the sacrifice we also think
about the real importance of diplomatic
initiatives now in the present day to
make sure that we don't have unnecessary
conflict or diplomatic initiatives what
what are those lessons do you think
though well the the League of Nations
was set up after the first world war and
the United Nations after the Second
World War and however imperfect it is
having a rules-based system having unity
amongst the sensible nations of the
world if you like trying to make sure
that we do talk rather than fight is
just very very important and it worries
me very considerably when we see some no
rather inappropriate
perhaps flaunting of those those rules
well I think there are two things I
think certainly we've seen some very
aggressive acts by some nations such as
Russia for example but I also think
we've seen the den agree
by Trump of some of those very
institutions that we rely on to keep
that peace and what did you make Donald
Trump's decision do you not visit the
war cemetery in France yesterday because
of the bad weather I was absolutely
horrified quite frankly when you think
of the sacrifice that people made and I
think people up and down the country and
across Europe whatever their political
views do think that it's very very
important that we commemorate what
happened and I think people were really
taken aback by that I think he made a
serious miss judge Monteux about the
mood across Europe I want to talk to you
about some comments that were made over
this week by a very prominent Labour
Party supporter about the poppy and
Aaron Bustani who is one of your most
high-profile activation who stays and
well he's very active on social media
said this I think the Poppy Appeal is
grotesque it has a kind of triumphalist
militarism about it it's racist right
it's right super white supremacists I
mean you're wearing a poppy well well
this is absolute nonsense and first of
all I must say this person no way
represents the name of party and I can
assure you that up and down the country
labour politicians will be proudly
wearing their puppy today they will be
at the Cenotaph this morning and they
recognize the huge sacrifice it has been
made by our armed forces both in the
first world war and in conflict since
and they recognized that this is a time
we come together and we remember and
that there has been so much good work
done by the Royal British Legion that I
finally know that the comments that that
this single person made completely I'm
representative and quite frankly an
utter disgrace I mean you say that's not
representative but here's somebody who
is a very prominent cheerleader for
Jeremy Corbyn he has a very large social
media following I mean should he be
thrown out the party well he's one
individual he's one individual who's put
his views up on on on social media and I
can assure you he really does not
represent mainstream feeling within the
party personally I think in remarks are
absolutely abhorrent should have been
found well I would like him to to
retract on those comments I certainly
would
whether he's to be thrown out is a
matter for the party to consider
okay thank you now later on the show
we're gonna be seeing what happens when
I sat down with three veterans who
talked very frankly about mental health
and some of the issues that members of
our armed forces face when they leave
the army and the lack of support the
fact that you know there are and sadly
so many people who take their own lives
what's Labour's position on how is your
tackle - well we want to see a really
joined-up approach right across
government it's very important that when
people leave the forces many of them
transition extremely well into civilian
life but for those who need extra
support it should be there and it has to
be a joined up process right across
government so what we set out as our
strategy is to make sure that we have
the funding in to ensure that mental
health provision is there for those that
need it
that we deal with the housing crisis so
that there are houses available and we
get rid of the scourge of rough sleeping
and that we also make absolutely certain
that the skills that the veterans have
are properly recognized and that if they
need additional support to get
additional qualifications or
apprenticeships or a first job interview
that the support is there to do that
because obviously they do have skills
they're not necessarily recognized by
employers and it's important that they
get into a successful second career and
they also have housing and then they
also have access to proper mental health
services those that recognition of
skills actually something that they sort
directly spoke about Imagineers
interesting - he say that and another
leg of party policy that was keen to
touch about is Trident now currently of
course is Labour's policy to renew
nuclear deterrent however the shoddy
peace minister had Fabien Hamilton
carrying out a review to see if
alternative jobs can be found for those
people working in the defense industry
he says he hopes that he sincerely hopes
that the review he's undertaking will
convince people to drop their support of
Trident so what's happening there okay
it's trying definitely going to be in
labour party policy going forward well
we are absolutely committed to the
Trident program the decision was taken
2,000 was taken back in 2007 and it's
settled Labour Party policy
now Fabian Hamilton can express his own
views but for the you know the the
mainstream Labour Party position on this
is that we are totally committed to the
Trident nuclear deterrent and you
mustn't muddle up the Trident nuclear
deterrent and the whole issue of
industrial diversification yeah but at
the same time though this is one of your
junior Shadow Cabinet ministers may he
does speak for the party and he's very
clear that he says that you know he's
always said that party policy should
renew tried it but I say we should scrap
it that's also the view the leaders a
party and he sincerely hopes review he's
undertaking will convince unions to drop
their support as well well as I say
they're not very helpful if you if
you're wildly in favor of keeping quiet
there are two very separate issues first
and foremost we are committed to the
deterrent that turns is extremely
important it's a very important part of
our defence policy and so we went there
we made the decision to renew it back in
2007 and obviously that's now eleven
years ago and the process is well down
the line now in terms of defence
diversification we have taught in a very
different way about industrial
diversification because we recognize
that there is immense inequality across
the regions of the UK and we recognize
that part of ensuring that no region is
too dependent for example on the coal
industry or the steel industry is to
make sure that there is better
redistribution of opportunity so that
people in every area of the UK have good
opportunities for further career
opportunities and now I'm keen to talk
to you as well about Brad said and
Jeremy Corbyn gave an interview this
week and he was asked if he would stop
brexit if he could and we could have a
look at the answer that he gave on
brexit he said we can't stop it the
referendum took place article 50 has
been triggered is your leader right to
say though you can't stop brexit well I
think the the decision was taken back in
2016 and very clearly the people of the
UK voted to leave the European Union you
can't stop a country if you wanted to
well what we want to see is a proper
deal because I know that many of those
people who voted leave certainly did not
want to see jobs and the economy
decimated they wanted to see it breaks
it that were
for jobs in the economy not the sort of
factionism we're seeing in the Tory
Party now at the same time though I
can't help but thinking that if this is
right that Jeremy Corbyn believes you
can't stop brexit then the motion you
pass at your conference was basically a
bit of a con because that said if we
cannot get a general election labour
must support all options remaining on
the table including campaigning for a
public vote but your leader is saying
that brexit can't be stopped
well those things don't add up to that
well I think you have to take things
step by step we've said very very
clearly we do not want a situation of no
deal we've also said very clear that we
cannot be voting for a bad deal or a
blind breaks it so what we are saying is
we need to resume now to come back with
a proper deal which protects jobs and
the economy which gives us that closest
possible relationship to the single
market and that's the sort of deal we
want to see on the table so any hand
brexit Lee stops well I think the the
answer to that is that we are we are
committed to getting a breaks if that
works we want to break it that works in
terms of jobs and the economy we are
prepared as Kier summers set out today
to work with MPs across the board to get
something which is workable and that's
where we are at this present time we
want to make sure is a second referendum
one of the options on the table well in
our in our view what we actually need to
do is get a proper deal that works now
if this government is incapable of
negotiating that deal then the best
option as far as we're concerned would
be to throw the government out and have
a team in there which can get a good
deal in other words we'd like to have a
general election if that's not an option
then we've said quite clearly we are
prepared to work across the board to try
and get a deal which would be workable
and I think the whole issue about a
people's vote arises because of the
prospect of a bad deal and I think if
for a good deal on the table that did do
as I've said protect jobs in the economy
then I think that issue would not be
half as vibrant as it is okay nee
Griffith thank you very much